i want winners 30 to one you hit it you
called it on the show
i'm happy my bank account's happening
i'm giving away hoodies all show you're
getting a hoodie for that you get a
hoodie
all three of you get hoodies mikey how
many hoodies you giving out today like
45
i'm not counting who knows it's time
we're all going in together
we have somebody here who likes to face
the group chat you guys are the absolute
worst
put some bleeping respect on my name why
are you even in this group chat you're
not even betting and not even telling me
i'm wrong
you have no original tapes get them out
again i don't want you in here get out
of the group chat
goodbye
[Music]
you just joined the br and group chat
we've got locks we've got hoodies we've
even got
junior from nba 2k i am
alongside kelly and vegas greg ivory
mikey quits and cavi richards we're
giving away hoodies all show
keep firing off your takes in the
comments that's right
i said mikey quit mikey explain what's
happening
please i just suck at gambling i can't
buy one right now vern i can't see one
go through the hoop i'm christopher
walken
i'm walking away from the game
how many bands i don't know cabbie i
can't say that
sometimes my wife walks oh first of all
first of all i cannot announce how many
bands i'm down
can i give away two hoodies real quick
give away a hoodie to make yourself feel
better
please kelly's gonna out this is the
only thing i have is giving away hoodies
uh i've got two
the most fired comment we asked you guys
combined points a.d hard and lebron
russ what will the combined total points
speed thank you for dropping your
predictions bucks are goaded
103 you can keep the hoodie i like the
confidence but i want to give you a
hoodie because that was a fire comment
and 132 132 total points
from debonw oh in virginia just so you
know my jacket size is 44 long
and my right arm is just a little bit
longer than my left great comment you
get a hoodie for that
i'm gonna go back to sulking in the
corner okay that's great
at the end of the show we're gonna let
you the audience have our first pick and
our first ever first basket proc
prop draft that's a lot of first tell us
about your favorite
first the first bucket in lakers rockets
game three
that's it yes someone wrote that and i
had to read it
you can bet on who's making the first
bucket in this game
and note the fanduel super boost on
anthony davis he's now offered at plus
490.
again you guys are getting the first
pick wool draft after
do not let us win drop your ticks now in
the comments we're giving out hoodies if
that wind
before we do that let's talk about our
first
our new favorite bet it's the same game
parlay
and we went we introduced it last week
and we went one for five it couldn't
have gone
worse we're going to redeem ourselves
now all right
we're feeling it are you guys feeling it
yeah
i'd rather go one and five than four and
five on a parlay straight up
that actually is factual good for you
mikey that is i like when you guys
go one in five though because when i
fade you guys
and hit four out of five straight back
this functional family member are you
what's going on here i thought we were a
family here
it's just messed up and it hurts my
feelings you know it's just one of those
things kathy it's like the people's
parlay last year during the betting show
like
it's a straight fade worthy bet and so
is this parlay
awful take you will do not fade us you
keep seeing it on social
people keep winning thousands of dollars
on the same day on
on the same game parlays is this
photoshop what's going on
[Music]
why can't this be me one time just one
a lot of people be dming me a lot of
photoshops i'd be
watching i'll be i'll be peeping that a
lot of guys be photoshopping me
trying to dm me saying that they won you
guys got to watch out with that watch
out for those
yeah garbage
no more photoshop fake clout it doesn't
mean anything we're gonna win some real
money
tonight we're cooking up one of our own
we're doing a five legger each one of us
takes a leg i'm going first
pj tucker over six and a half points two
corner threes
one free throw that's it he's hit it
easy one
vern i'm right there with you with
professional justice tucker his
office is the corner three he makes the
most corner threes in the association
one you know one not even a dribble bull
money
money i'm taking over one and a half
three-point shots
from professional justice tucker and
he's probably going to grab
10 boards as well but book it let's go
i respect the hell out of pj tucker dude
because he just sits in the corner
he's not contested a lot and he might
miss five freeze in a row but he keeps
shooting them because he knows he has to
for that offense
he's like you're better shooting instead
i am retired i like those bats i like
the rockets tonight
uh i like harden over 30 and a half
that's gonna be my sprinkle here
when we hit this five team same game
parlay we make 18k
and then we're kings and queens again
could i be back all right yeah
listen mikey i like that i think you're
back i think you're back i like that
hard and over
i wanted to take anthony davis under
point total
uh because i do like the rockets now
i got told that was bad vibes so
whatever
i guess i'm gonna go with like a little
little action here
with mikey i think if harden goes over
it's because he
and westbrook have a monster night
together i like westbrook
to have a bounce back tonight give me
the westbrook point total over
it looks like you guys it looks like you
guys created a trend
i see everybody on the houston rockets
so
uh why don't i join the train i'm
rocking with my guy
robert covington i'm rocking with my guy
robert covington to go
over eleven and a half points i mean
for that one he balled in that okc
series and he bawled last game he scored
17.
so uh in that houston offense where they
just put up a lot of shots
i'm liking my chances with robert
covenant
uh hitting 12 points at least it's
official then we're all over the rockets
we've got pj tucker james harden russ
westbrook and roco over
points look it pays out over 1701 on
that
all right i love it all houston all
day i hope people are riding with us
mikey
kmart 219 and there's a lot of words
here so i don't think i can get through
it without
messing up and not summarizing reading
but the square bet of the day is on
houston
the line has moved but i'm expecting the
lakers to take control of the paint with
a.d
and cruise again to a win on the square
want to tell that guy about reverse line
movement
that's not smart can we check that uh
jake the snake 27 side bet br mikey
locks is down 1500 on the week
it's tuesday last week i would take the
over this week i'm retired so let's
no way you're retired you are not
retired
we have college we have nfl on thursday
we have college football on saturday we
have nfl on sunday we got nba
all week long we got baseball and nhl
there is no way
you are making it to monday without
making a bet that's a great point i
don't think he's making it to wednesday
that is a good point it's happening all
right
we just built our same game parlay mikey
you thank you for participating even if
you quit i want to know what is our
favorite kind of parlay in general
tell us in the comments as always we'll
give you a hoodie
if you found one we missed mikey what
are you what are you which i need to
know
the people's favorite parlays for me i
just mentioned it
i'm a big monday through sunday guy i
like to at the end of the week be up i
never want to go
into sunday night and be down money so
at the end
of the week when you do the sunday night
chase parlay sunday night baseball
sunday night football sprinkle in a
little cricket tennis rugby i don't care
what it is
whatever it is to get me back to even so
on monday morning i am getting a venmo
not sending one
that's huge for me
when i go to the buffet i like to sample
from all
all sorts of things i gotta start with
my fried rice i'm gonna put a little
broccoli in there a little fried shrimp
little some chicken fingers you know you
don't just stop at at the spring rolls
so i need the same game parlor
multiple props from one game i'm in
vegas
maybe that's what we do buffets for life
is the
analogy cabbie's actually not in vegas
we even know the buffets are closed
right now
in spirit if it's all the same game why
would he be eating all different things
at a buffet it doesn't make sense
look you've got different players
they're not all the same players in one
game and they're not
they also options this is how you have
to be you got to get prime rib
then you got to get fried rice then you
got to get ice cream then you got to get
waffles that time i have no
idea what the hell you guys are talking
about i'm so confused right now
this is this is the same game game let's
go it's called the feast
same game parlay that's what i'm eating
on
kelly what do you what are you please
listen we already know how i feel about
parlays they're called sucker bets for a
reason
you do not bet parlays they do not pay
true odds
but we all know that every single
college football saturday and every once
in a while on an nfl sunday
i parlay three dogs on the money line to
win outright
usually all at better than 175 plus 175
i will only bet parlays if they pay 25
to 1 or higher you guys stop bed and
parlays you're not going to win
do those ever hit yeah i hit two lashes
i don't know your
voice went way over here kelly yeah that
was a voice crack
yeah that's a that was lying i didn't
ring true that's crazy
all right i've got the exact opposite of
kelly's pick here
i like parlay two money line favorites
you take a team that's minus 220.
you take a team that's minus 180. you
sandwich them together
you got an even money meal right there
all you got to do is pick two winners
it's easy greg i'm gonna let you go but
let me own vern really quick here
he wants to lay 180 parlayed with minus
260. yeah
and get what you don't even barely get
even
money on our leg maybe and that's
implied odds that you have to win
over 70 percent of the time what that
are you doing with your life right now
what are you doing
that sounds like smart money well
why are you guys even arguing who made
this segment
favorite kind of parlays like what is
this
if you parlay you parlay anything you
parlay any type of parlay give me the
sunday night chase
give me the same game give me the plus
money give me the favorites just give me
any parlay
actually you guys know what to do dm me
your locks
if i like them i'm gonna parlay it it's
simple
that's what i do a guy who has a parlay
song that i've heard him sing on
multiple occasions yes
we gotta bring it back parlay farley
farley farley
if you guys win a parlay send me a video
doing the
singing the parlay song doing the dance
we'll post it yes let's go parlay's all
day baby
mikey what are the comments saying i
love that all right we got a couple here
greg i think i found your burner going
into sunday parlay the niners with
anything
that is a guaranteed lock gosh
you get a hoodie for that i like that
that's what that's what i'm saying
though
not a ton of different parlays in here
i'm with greg you can't discriminate
against any of them they're like your
children we love all of them
we're taking all of them all right i
know where it's
excited for today's game we got four
series happening right now though
let's talk tomorrow is anybody feeling
strongly about the boston
toronto series aka course what kind of
equipment
just stop right there burn stop right
there what kind of a question is that
before someone is feeling setting you up
and emotional
about the celtics and the raptor series
we're talking about the defending
nba champions cabbie so yeah
we're i'm back i'm feeling great about
factors in seven
stop in seven you're feeling great
cabbie
what what hold on time out this series
is over bro we shouldn't even be in this
game that that they're going to play
tomorrow
we shouldn't even be here the series is
over what are the raptors going to do
differently please tell me
brad wanna maker is not going to have
drop another 15 points against the
raptors jaylen brown had a nice game
but the celtics aren't going to shoot 50
percent in game six and 50
in game seven and the raptors definitely
aren't going to shoot 30 percent
from the land beyond you know what you
know what they're gonna do you know what
they're gonna do you know what they're
going to do
they have the coach of the year and nick
nurse and he's going to game plan
even if serge ibaka isn't a hundred
percent marcus
two-time defensive player of the year
one-time defensive player nba
championship this is amazing
he's gonna get back just get on the
versa climber
a little bit you know uh uh on
his game cabbie
so you're telling me nick's nurse is
gonna have input on them winning
tomorrow of course
he's one of the most brilliant ones and
kyle lowry is the second smartest player
in the association
playing after lebron oh my god seven i'm
done with this
i'm going to have larry needs to stop
crying over fouls
nick nurse i mean he's a good coach but
he's
he's not going to be able to do anything
he's not going to be able to do
anything in order for them to win
tomorrow he's not playing mark the souls
he's watched he's
he's done who else who else did you name
who else
marcus lowry cabbies
pascal is going to refine his he's going
to find his form
he hasn't really been this guy's in
worse form than i am right now bro
he's doing it for you dad pascal ciaco
is going to bounce back
like big sean said last night i took an
l but tonight i bounce back
tomorrow they'll bounce back
stop it would you guys like
that was incredible someone save us
clippers nuggets does anyone have
anything there
i got you vern i got you burn i mean
i've been telling you guys since the
beginning before the bubble
hop on the clippers bandwagon they are
gonna go all the way so i'm still
rocking with them i do see them winning
this series
but the nuggets do have value with those
point spreads uh
they have been hidden so uh i don't know
kelly what are you yeah i mean greg was
right he was on the clippers early i
said there was no value i'm betting him
to win the western conference
there's really not a ton of value in
laying all these points with the
clippers either because as we've seen
night in night out especially mikey
locks
he knows they just don't care about
covering the spread they're up
six or up seven they've gotta win by
nine
they just don't care uh also look the
nuggets
had the opportunity to help me out on
the over last night and you know what
they did
they just dribbled the ball out and i
got stuck with a push
either way i'll be on the nuggets plus
the points by tip but
no there's no value on them benny feels
too bad don't feel too bad i lost my
over yesterday by the hook
oh well let's bring cabbie back in let's
get him back in the comments right now
has anyone checked on the ems or the ems
report on montrez herald
because he was baptized by michael
porter jr last night
and we don't even know if he has any
vital signs he won the sixth man of the
year but that trophy was dismantled
by a rookie named michael porter jr so
he's not even gonna be a factor in game
four because
my guy is doing one of these right now
you know what that was amazing what you
just came in with mikey what are the
comments saying while we all take that
in
kelly you said the clippers don't care
about covering the spread do
any teams care about covering the spread
you do you have some knowledge that we
don't have listen we know that certain
teams have a little more insight into
what the spread is but also the clippers
are overvalued in the close proximity to
vegas
vegas is always going to be heavy on the
raiders they're always going to be heavy
on the golden knights the lakers
the chargers the ramps la is
infiltrated vegas right now so you have
to lay a premium
with la teams and that's just what it
really boils down to
do the clippers really care maybe maybe
they don't no they don't seems like they
don't
bev was getting two technicals to cost
me lots and lots of money
on that live line and i'll never forgive
him for it so kelly i'm with you i
thought about being one of those people
that like
sends those long emails that we always
see on the br betting instagram
of like complaining asking if you're
gonna write adam silver and email
i i might do it i'll i would advise
craft it
bring your job but you don't do that
okay he doesn't care about his job he
already said he's going to go be like
a girlfriend or something i don't want
to i don't i'm eric bledsoe i don't want
to be here
uh clippers will finish it tomorrow
chris david says
flyers fan oh eight agreed i see the
clippers
nobody is hearing denver maybe you did a
little sprinky
on that fern what do you think murray i
think you should give someone a hoodie
i just gave two hoodies away for those
clippers takes you didn't say that
you didn't did you say hoodie well
that's why you're here when i fall down
you're my blood brother you pick me back
up
and that's what i was doing but you
should be explicit you know not everyone
can read your mind
write that down and take that feedback
so i really get it for next time
thank you so much we asked on social for
the combined point totals
of 80 lebron russ and hardin
you guys have been weighing in and look
someone told me this
if you add it all up their individual
point total equals 113.
so that's what we're playing with here
but the question is simple
who is going off tonight from this group
oh that's easy that's russell westbrook
the third
my guy was watching film in between
games two and three
hopefully watching film of himself when
he was dismantling opponents in january
and february
he struggled in game two only had ten
points
my guy shot seven three-pointers which
he hasn't shot that many three pointers
since christmas
one for seven that's not going to happen
he's going back to the mid-range he's
got that mamba dna
and he's gonna be volcanic playoff rondo
can't guard westbrook
kcp can't guard westbrook nobody can
guard westbrook
lebron did have a few blocks but what
i'm saying is westbrook is gonna be back
that 22 and a half take
over on fanduel because number number
zero
is going to be dropping a whole bunch of
mother bleepers
the whole game looking at the virtual
fans screaming
ah and mother bleep you so russell
wesley who gave cabbie this much coffee
today
we might have to keep going again
don't kick them out don't take them off
that was a good time
that was a good thing i'm right there
with you i'm right there with you riding
with russell westbrook
i do think he's gonna have a rebound
game today
uh we're gonna see a lot of you rock the
babies tonight
uh i see him going over 22 and a half
points i
this should be easy for him he's a he's
a future hall of famer usually future
hall of famers they they bounce back
i mean the best they bounce back so i
see him bouncing back
uh so let's go rush i'm putting my money
on you what's
westbrook too busy throwing it to the
other team says shane k26
hey guy five i never win anything let me
get a hoodie
and watch me frame that mf all right you
get a hoodie a guy five but i wanna see
the screenshot you gotta follow through
you need to frame that
put it in the game room put mikey flops
on the back greg might even sign it for
you
uh look i'm taking over in this game i
think
like i said the rockets are gonna go off
give me harden over 30 and a half that
line should be
34. uh i'm also terrible at betting so
you should probably fade me i don't know
i got no fight mikey i'm with you
we're all on the rockets kelly suggested
she likes the over
that means james harden over 30 and a
half points i'm just putting the pieces
together here all the pieces fit they
all matter
it's hardened over 30 and a half can i
have a lot
no alone i thought you weren't betting
why do you need a loan
let's all find it we got him ladies and
gentlemen
we got it right it's a lifeline you're
right
kelly what are you taking uh you as you
mentioned vern
i do like the game over and when you're
taking prop bets you want them to
correlate with how you see the game
playing out so just for fun
i'll sprinkle a little bit on the west
brook and hardin
little two little two teamer here with
the prop bets give me something to cheer
for for my over
those two go off that over's hidden easy
interesting that's a lot like my uh
two team moneyline favorites except it
pays almost three to one
all right it pays a little better but i
don't know
you're just taking two favorites mikey
what are the people saying here
people are really confused about what's
going on going on with cabbie what just
happened
cabbie crying face crying face all caps
i think cabbie's going off today he's
the mvp deke the geek
it was pretty funny though i'll give you
a hoodie for that one all right
it is time for our first ever first
basket prop
draft that's right it's a draft tell us
who you think is gonna hit the first
bucket in this lakers rockets game
fanduel has the super
boosty wusty on anthony davis
but he had a little boosty a little
woosty he was plus 390.
now he's being offered at plus 490. you
the audience will get your first pick
so start dropping your ticks now in the
comments
we are giving away hoodies of fists hits
while you drop your takes in the
comments while you maybe take that
boosty woost
mikey are you really gonna quit betting
we need you
i need you please please
give me something i need a lock like i
need one of these fur boos to hit so i
can get back
close to even so yeah vern maybe i could
get back into it
if you'd stop being so selfish and give
me two three hundred dollars
let's not go down that route but yeah i
could get back into bed with that it's
amazing
i'm just gonna leave the industry
amazing i'm kidding
i'm quitting betting i might quit bleach
report betting because every time i come
to work
i talk about betting and then you guys
peer pressure me into making a bet
so i probably just need to go for it you
have any self-control michael
uh maybe a maybe uh working bed bath and
beyond i don't know there's options out
there for me
could be a dog walker uh i think i need
to get a new job isn't sales you look
like a t-shirt
a t-shirt maker t-shirt guy yeah greg
let's collab
i think you got some fire ideas oh you
like have a cart in vegas on the
sidewalk of t-shirts
i used to be a better something like
that i think that's your future
kelly do people ask for loans in vegas
like
is this a normal thing among bettors
what do you do if one of your friends
asked you for
her loan to bed oh you kick him to the
curb
a great question for betty i'm good for
it you guys yeah
i mean do they have a regular job do
they how are they gonna pay me back
i don't know i mean if we're sending the
book and you're waiting for a ticket to
cash and you're like yo throw me 300
so i can go bet this sure that's no
problem but if it's like you've just
gotten slaughtered all day and you just
want to chase the sunday night game like
at some point time i have to be the
voice of reason okay
that's no fun mikey what are the people
saying the people can be our voice of
reason
what is going to be the first pick here
in our first bucket prop draft
chief chief and says someone tell aaron
rodgers clone to give me a hoodie please
do you think he's talking about you or
me
i think he's talking about you vern
looks like you get a hoodie for
a big ben right here aaron rodgers uh so
for the first
bucket this guy named josh colin
okay has commented about 15 times i
don't know why
he wants this so bad but because of that
he skewed the votes
first bucket by a.d he liked the boosty
roosty vern
uh so the first pick from the people is
anthony davis on the boosting
what do you call it or
a soupy whoopee either that's neither
lands but it's
we're gonna take nope you didn't like
that okay we're gonna do our own
i've got all our names in a hat here
we're drawing them out at random
let's see this is legit
and unfortunately mikey locks has
the first pick here mikey who you gonna
take i'm pretty upset man i want to take
javale
but cabbie was telling me that he might
have a little ankle issue
no he does have all he could i will be
he may not play but he might have
it's questionable that he plays he might
have an ankle issue
i think with the first pick in the draft
we're not really talking about odds here
you don't need to take the highest odds
so with that being said
i'll take robert covington plus 1500.
okay it's good value it's gonna hit next
pick here goes to cabbie
the buffet man okay the houston rockets
have not won a tip the entire playoffs
they are 0.9
so that means the los angeles lakers are
going to win the tip that's likely
anthony davis
ball gets to brawn and braun because he
is
such an intelligent basketball player
he's like i got to get my guy going
and you know who i have to get going
because he's struggling the first two
games
danny green opened in the corner for a
three-point shot
book it that's who i got my money on
plus 1 000 on fanduel
that's value all day give me danny green
a
an nbh a two-time nba champion most
recently with the toronto raptors thank
you very much
does he like buffets that was that was
redeeming
i'm glad you didn't take fred man bleep
for this uh that would have been a good
calculation
wrong game wrong game here we go here we
go
well i know i just thought he would have
done it anyway out of just like he's
such a raptors fan
kelly congratulations you have now have
the third pick
so this is just like a fantasy football
draft
why mikey took joe mixon instead of
cmc is beyond me and why cabbie took
i don't know who julio jones instead of
saquon barkley is also beyond me
2020 why were we doing snake drafts in
the first place go play yourself in
come on snake jerry don't don't throw
shades make drafts they're still legit
yeah fake drafts
feige you're done you took a 15-1 when
you had first pick
you have to take the most obvious pick
here
as cabbie alluded to the lakers are
probably gonna win the tip because
well the rockets don't have the size to
win the tip
that being said i gotta go with lebron
how does nobody take braun here
plus four bucks almost come on you guys
it's the obvious pick he's gonna score
first
he leads the league and assists kelly i
know the whole football he's going to
take this one to the hole
why is this about football i'll catch
you up on it later because it's football
season bird why are we still talking
about basketball
burn slack i'll cut you up bro it's the
nba playoffs greg
you have just pulled out the next pick
uh
okay so i see this
uh lakers win the tip they missed the
first shot
and the rockets have the ball usually
when that happens the ball is in james
harden hand
so with that being said
i see my guy james harden clear out
everybody iso e mono
braun come here dribble dribble
tween tween step back
pop give me james harden
for the first basket of the game let's
go
lock it in john is not going to be
guarding james harden from the jump that
that's impossible i'm here he says come
here i'm going hey you never know
you never know they always they always
you know switch switcheroo switches
the rockets go on the break here comes
russ we all have his
over down down the court down the lane
the lakers collapse they don't want to
let them get going pj tucker
wide open three in the corner he's
halfway to our same game parlay
give me pj tucker first bucket
you guys like that we're going to i do i
do 1400
but that's what you're supposed to do
when you have the fifth pick you take a
longer shot
thank you i don't know kelly i have a
question for you mikey why do you hate
that
what mike it's just a it's just a bad
pic kelly are we just in the show
no no i have a question i got things
very serious are you are you locked in
yeah i need to break the losing streak
what if i were to place a bet on
lakers minus five and rockets plus five
so then i just see the green check mark
next to one of the bets and then the
losing just
to see one go for the vibes you're
willing to donate 10 percent
yeah to just cash one to our good
friends at fanduel yes
sounds like greg all right
all right somebody kick me out of this
group check it's clearly i have taught
mikey
nothing lost you guys remember
what kelly and we all have taught you
here today don't listen to mikey number
one
we are getting rich on our lakers
rockets same game parlay
always hammer any kind of parlay that's
the great special especially
when you're down there's a little mikey
locks and if you guys
and you guys picked anthony davis to
score the first bucket
if he gets it we're giving away hoodies
be on the lookout
and if you already want a hoodie today
we will dm you
so keep checking your messages thank you
guys for watching
i'm worried about mikey locks i hope
he's still on the show next week
i'm leaving the chat though we'll see
you guys poorly
nope won't be here barley parlay parlay
partly